so as we pick up with part three of DC
versus marvel this is when we start to
get into the idea that not everything is
crazy battle high-octane instead we
actually pick up with Jubilee and Tim
Drake now the funny thing about this is
when Tim Drake was teleported to the
room of Jubilee they had begun talking
with one another and Jubilee had
actually sort of fallen in love even
though it was a very very short amount
of time the O Jubilee had always tried
to find you know mr. right so to speak
despite being a teenager being a young
girl she was always a reflection of the
teenage readers who were going through
Marvel Comics at the time which is one
of the reasons why she was so popular
this was compounded with the fact that
in the cartoon show x-men the animated
series
she was us as the reader in this
universe of X again she really you know
she reflected us you know the fans who
were running around in this reality
where things were absolutely insane but
after being teleported to a strange
warehouse of sorts both Jubilee and Tim
Drake are forced to do battle against
one another and so of course again
because this is not a battle to the
death their goal isn't to kill each
other other goal is to just defeat one
another and so this is this is basically
what happens while they're going through
Jubilees using her little fireworks and
so on and so forth but with Tim Drake
he's received such prodigious training
from that man that he knows how to evade
individuals who do have powers and this
is what he does he starts dodging
Jubilee he basically avoids her eye
contact and he runs away and her initial
thought is simply trying to locate him
but it's difficult to do because he
keeps hiding in the shadows now
eventually she stumbles upon his cape
but when she goes to it she realizes
it's a trap and Tim Drake comes up
behind her throws his lasso around her
and basically and snares her and so
again this is a little bit of romance
here you know this is just a little bit
of showing us that things aren't
terrible you know that that sometimes
you know good things come out of
situations like this and so all the to
share a little bit of romantic banter
between the between themselves and you
know of course while Tim droid goes to
let her go we end up transitioning to
space and we pick up with Kyle Rayner
the Green Lantern and Silver Surfer now
those of you guys who were current Green
Lantern readers this may be something
that you guys will really really really
anticipating because a battle between
the Green Lantern and silver surfers is
on par with the incredible hold versus
of Superman which is actually a conflict
we'll see in this story neo between
Batman and black panther or Punisher or
somebody like that it just seems to make
sense you know it's just two similar
characters Green Lantern's deal with
space the Silver Surfer deals with space
it'd be interesting to see the battle
between them between each other now the
one thing also take note of here is that
these two Silver Surfer and Green
Lantern have met before there was
actually a story called unholy alliances
that dealt with Hal Jordan who is still
operating under the mantle of parallax
as the main enemy and both Halloween ER
and Silver Surfer joining forces to
defeat Hal Jordan the issue here is what
Silver Surfer says is that the powers of
these brothers who are basically kind of
screwing with reality are well beyond
even those of Galactus and so because
the Silver Surfer you know is a Herald
of Galactus and because he's used to
such incredible power the fact that
these brothers have power that goes well
beyond Galactus means that they're not
to be trifled with
and so Silver Surfer and Green Lantern a
kind of in a situation from surfers
perspective anyway that they cannot
avoid this conflict and so this is
really what kyle raiders popularity came
into play for those of you guys who
don't know you know Hal Jordans comics
just weren't selling you know in in
really the 60s 70s 80s and early 90s the
four decades they were just not selling
and try as they might could not make him
popular and so what they did is they
chose to ride him out with the story
Emerald Twilight and they replaced him
with cow in a car and it was a lot more
popular because he was an artist and he
would use his Green Lantern ring to make
all kinds of crazy things like what
you're seeing here you know or yet has a
giant horse even has armor and so on and
so forth you know whereas Hal Jordan
would use his ring to make like giant
hands and fists and different things
like that the result is that the two of
them you know Silver Surfer in and Kalla
later basically charged at one another
in something that's a little bit
anti-climatic and a result of this
massive explosion and Silver Surfer is
completely unfazed or seems to be
completely unfazed and so this is
basically Marvel and DC telling us that
the Silver Surfer is more powerful then
Kyle Rayner now something that I also
want to address here is Kyle Rayner the
white Lantern as it exists right now if
Silver Surfer we're to go against Kyle
Rayner as the white lantern it would be
no contest Silver Surfer would probably
be
litter ated but you know again this is
just another example of sort of
inspiring debate so I'm curious leave a
comment down below in terms of who you
think would win the Silver Surfer or the
White Lantern Kyle Rayner I have a
feeling a lot of responses will be white
lantern Callaway no but what we do here
is we switch over to Selina Kyle and
Elektra now this is one of the
interesting situations you know with
this with a story because these are
characters who are both villains but
they could not be any more opposite and
what I mean by that is while you know
Selina Kyle is very formidable in terms
of her fighting abilities she's not an
assassin but Elektra is Elektra is a
prodigious assassin probably the best
assassin in the world and the result is
that she's ruthless she has no real
qualms with killing people and this is a
point that she makes - Selina Kyle you
know while the two of them were fighting
one another you know Elektra is at least
originally it seems to be bound by
Selina and her whips but electorate
Elektra turns the tables and she
basically has Selina Kyle off the edge
you know with Selina Kyle hang on to her
whip and then Elektra says as an
assassin she has her own code of conduct
she has her own moral compass that she
follows she's only willing to kill those
this she agrees to kill but she's
basically been forced into the situation
and she says that she will not kill
Selina Kyle but she still wants to win
and so the result is that she suffers
the rope Selina Kyle collapses down you
know falls into this giant thing of sand
and she basically following conscious
meaning that Elektra is now the victor
in this situation and so because the
Daily Planet you know of course is again
under the control of Jay jonah Jameson
and it exists to sell itself is
basically keeping track of everything
that's happened so far so what we know
is that between the heroes and the
villains from Marvel and DC who've been
fighting one another so far the battle
is three and three it's deadlocked you
know it's it's it's completely even and
we pick up with Lois Lane and Ben Riley
operating as Peter Parker and what
happens here is is actually kind of
funny you Ben Riley and previously
rescued you know Lois Lane from the
clutches of the Scarecrow you know
and I kind of become smitten with her
you know had sort of developed an
attraction towards her and he actually
hits on her he actually asked her you
know if she wants to go get dinner
sometime and she says that she's engaged
and then of course Superman immediately
pops up you know Clark Kent shows up and
said that he you know he's the one that
she's engaged to and been violent just
kind of takes off you know he's
extremely embarrassed about the
situation you know he's extremely
embarrassed about what it was that
happened but what we also do is we
switch back to the character of access
now I know we haven't been I haven't had
a lot of explanation on him and there's
a reason for that
you know the reason is actually when to
wait until this video to do that what
we're told is that you know access is
yet another in a long line of
gatekeepers is the best way to explain
it you know in this story what Marvel
and DC establish is that there is
effectively kinda like a barrier a
dimensional wall between the model and
the DC universes and the role of you
know this kid axel who's going by the
name access and those that came before
him specifically the the homeless man
who's basically his mentor has been to
always be to get keepers who always
ensure that these universes never
crossed over and that's one of the
reasons why characters cross over
occasionally because sometimes you know
it would happen without access knowing
that it happened and then they would go
back to the respective universes and
that breach would be sealed the result
is that access is I guess access is kind
of like this the shard of both realities
merged into a singular being which
explains why he's capable of jumping
back and forth between the Marvel and
the DC universes which is actually
something that we'll see come into play
later on but in truth he's really just a
plot device you know he's really just a
way for Marvel and DC to kind of get
themselves an out when it comes to the
end of the story something that we'll
see they're in desperate need of you
know by the time it all is all said and
done but we end up switching you know
out in space then we pick up with
Wolverine and we pick up with Lobo now
one thing I also want to point out here
is that these characters are being
teleported you know Wolverines being
teleported by the brothers to the realm
of Lobo he's not simply just getting in
a vehicle and taking off into space but
again because this is being played so so
fast and loose even if that wasn't the
case we would just kind of have to
accept that Wolverine is in space right
now fighting Lobo but one of the big
downsides here is that a majority of
this conflict actually takes place off
panel you know with Wolverine having a
healing factor and having adamantium
claws adamantium is the strongest metal
in existence and what
DC seemed to be saying here is that it's
the strongest metal in existence whether
it's Marvel or DC and that's exactly
what happens he basically takes the
fight of course with a scaling factor
he's able to deal with the the blows of
Lobo and they start fighting each other
behind a bar and the result is we don't
see a lot of what happens we don't
really see who it is you know I guess
how Lobos defeated all we know is that
Wolverine is the person who comes out on
top
smoking the cigar and and this is a is
it really designed to be a serious thing
because of the fact that Wolverine was
so over-the-top and crazy in terms of
his character development DC responded
by creating Lobo who is designed to be
over-the-top and crazy designed to be a
parody basically of Wolverine and so
this is just kind of a really designed
to be a comedic thing you know to be
honest this design - oh just too
ridiculously over-the-top characters
fighting against one another but at this
point we jump back to Wonder Woman and
again in the last video we had talked
about how Wonder Woman had discovered
the hammer of Thor and she succeeded in
picking it up and when she did it made
her you know Wonder Woman with all the
powers of Thor changed her outfit the
whole nine yards but for her because
she's gonna be fighting in storm and
because when a woman is a woman of honor
having the hammer would destroy any
chance that storm has of being
successful and so Wonder Woman actually
drops that she abandons the power of
Thor and just decides to fight you know
the storm one-on-one mano a mano
the problem with this is that despite
her vaunted strength despite her you
know her ability to fly and so on and so
forth storm controls the elements and
that's the one thing that Wonder Woman
seems powerless against and that's
exactly what happens you know storm
starts calling down the the power of
electricity and she just keeps shocking
you know Wonder Woman over and over
again but what also happens here is
storm begins to develop a respect for
Wonder Woman no it's not to say they
didn't have a respect for each other
before but with storm because she is you
know such a strong female character it's
kind of extending that you know with
Wonder Woman being from famous Kyra
because she's raised or was raised in a
society where it was it was
predominantly women and it was women
have you know those those women having a
sort of a code of honor among themselves
it extends to both storm and Wonder
herself you know and so storm sees her
very much times really a biological
sister but as you know a sister on a
very personal level in the sense that
they you know they formed a kind of bond
here you know that they have respect for
one another and so in the end door
improves to be successful against Wonder
Woman and in the end you know she kind
of cradles her in her arms it apologizes
for attacking her in such a way but you
know storm of course comes out on top
here and so what we do is we switch to a
Greenwich Village and we pick up with
Superboy Conner Kent and we pick up with
Ben Riley now because of the fact that
Monell versus or I guess DC versus
Marvel was a story that those who
wouldn't normally read comics when in
God for people who were getting into the
story at the time there was some
explanation on who these characters were
Conner Kent was one in particular
because a lot of fans who weren't
reading you know comics after the death
of Superman you know didn't really know
who Conner Cain was they saw him as
Superboy but they didn't know anything
beyond that and so this is what's kind
of given to us you know Ben Riley asked
the question you know who are you what
is it that you're capable of and you
know Conner Kent says that he's
basically a clone of Superman you know
he emerged after Superman supposedly
gone and you know and even then you know
it kind of takes Ben Rawley by surprise
she's like really yeah you know Chloe
and it's it's kind of a funny situation
but again it's just as on to sort of
refresh those of us who wouldn't
wouldn't have known about Conner Kent
and so while the two were going against
one another because of the fact that Ben
Riley has all the same powers as
spider-man Peter Parker he's able to
easily evade you know the attacks of
Superboy Superboy is fast he's very
powerful but Ben Riley has the
proportional strength of a spider and so
the result is that while the match seems
even between the two when is it
happening here is Ben Miley basically
outwits
Conner Kent he stands in front of an
electrical generator and when Conner
Kent comes charging towards him Ben
Riley jumps out of the way and then
covers him in impact webbing and allows
Superboy to be electrocuted to the point
where it basically just knocks him out
and so what we do here is we switch to
downtown metropolis and we pick up with
Professor Hulk now again this is the
Incredible Hulk with the mind of Bruce
Banner but it costs a portion of its
strength so this is not a full-powered
Incredible Hulk and that's a very
important difference to distinguish here
because in this conflict
metallo the villain of Superman is
basically wreaking havoc in downtown
metropolis and fighting against the
whole and so you know
what is up happening is that while the
hope is it least seems to be taking on
the towel a Superman makes his
appearance known the two of them team up
they defeat metallo but then they're
teleported away to you know the middle
of nowhere and they start fighting
against one another
the Matt the the battle actually seems
extremely even between the two and the
result is that Superman actually comes
out on top here but what he says is that
it took everything he had to take the
Incredible Hulk down now this is why I
say this is so important because if this
had been like savage fall if this had
been the Incredible Hulk from the
onslaught saga whose mind was removed
from the influence of Bruce Banner by
Jean Grey he probably would have taken
Superman out he probably would have
taken him out pretty easily to be quite
frank but because of the fact that this
is Professor Hulk because his strength
has been reduced you know Superman still
had to use everything he had and so once
you know once professor Hulk is knocked
unconscious the Superman basically just
lies in wait and so what we do is we
switch back to Manhattan and we pick up
with Batman and Captain America now as
the two of them are going against one
another Captain America is actually
getting really frustrated with Bruce
Wayne and the reason why is because
Bruce Wayne is a prodigious fighter when
it comes to you know hand-to-hand combat
as well as using his surroundings that
in fact a Bruce Wayne's ability to meld
into the shadows is really his strong
suit here and this is what happens
Captain America is great when it comes
to fighting a foe he can see he's
terrible when it comes to fighting a foe
he cannot see and Bruce Wayne picks that
up and begins using it to his advantage
he the problem with this is that because
the two are so evenly matched
Captain America comes to the conclusion
that one they've been fighting for hours
and two that would probably end up
fighting for days and so what he says is
that there their efforts are probably
better suited in finding a way to stop
the brothers from screwing with reality
as opposed to fighting themselves but in
the midst of you know this conversation
between the two of them the sewer system
is flooded with water and while Captain
America does try to throw his shield -
you know incapacity Batman he ends up
missing but Batman ends up hitting
Captain America with one of his
batteries and so you know Steve Rogers
is immersed in this water and seems to
be drowning and so while Batman does
make it to the top you know he swims
back down he grabs Steve Rogers and he
brings it back to the surface the
problem here is that because Steve Roger
was unconscious even if only for a
moment he you know Batman was basically
declared the victor but what is it
happening is that as they emerge from
the sewer system they're greeted by
access and his mentor and this is
basically where access provides an
explanation he simply says that he is a
character who represents a gateway
between these realities he represents a
way for you know Batman and Captain
America had to figure out I guess gain a
better understanding of what's going on
with these brothers but what isn't
happening is that while they are in the
middle of this conversation
the two brothers join hands with one
another and the two brothers stop
existing as individuals and they emerge
as a singular entity and what this did
is an allowed Marvel to go forward I
guess now Marvel and DC to go forward
creating something called the amalgam
universe now with that being said uh
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and we'll actually pick up with what the
amalgam universe is because in the next
video we'll run over it but I'm not
going to go super in-depth into it just
because you know the inaugural universe
was actually pretty huge there was a lot
to it but but anyway I'm gonna go ahead
and bring this to an end make sure you
guys hit the sub button if you're new
here become part of the report make sure
you hit the like button and make sure
you guys leave a comment let me know
what you guys think about this series so
far and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you